-Ah, he's one of my favorites.
His new album, "Young Blood," is out August 26th.
Performing "Hard Working Man," please welcome Marcus King!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Up late, all night ♪
♪ I don't even need a reason why ♪
♪ Your love is so right ♪
♪ I can't wait until the morning light ♪
♪ Get back when I'm through ♪
♪ Send my living on home to you ♪
♪ Hey, honey, don't you understand? ♪
♪ Been working all day, doin' the best I can ♪
♪ Got that easy lovin' if you'd take my hand ♪
♪ I'm a hard working man ♪
♪ I'm a hard-working man ♪
♪ Oh, yes, I am ♪
♪♪
♪ Just wait, payday ♪
♪ I'm gonna take you somewhere far away, baby ♪
♪ Us two, sky blue ♪
♪ First, I got to make a run or two ♪
♪ Bossman, he's on the line ♪
♪ Said he's gonna give me overtime, yes, he is, babe ♪
♪ Hey, honey, don't you understand? ♪
♪ Been working all day, doin' the best I can ♪
♪ Got that easy lovin' if you'd take my hand ♪
♪ I'm a hard working man ♪
♪ Bet your life that I am ♪
♪♪
♪ Hey, honey, don't you understand? ♪
♪ Been working all day, doin' the best I can ♪
♪ Got that easy lovin' if you'd take my hand ♪
♪ Lord, I'm a hard working man ♪
♪ I'm a hard-working man ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Hey, honey, don't you understand? ♪
♪ Been working all day, doin' the best I can ♪
♪ That easy lovin' if you'd take my hand ♪
♪ I'm a hard working man ♪
♪ I'm a hard-working man ♪
♪ Ohh-ohh ♪
♪ Bet your life I am, baby ♪
♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Working hard for you, darlin' ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
[ Finale plays ]
♪♪
-Jimmy: Ohh!